Hôm nay là nên bọn nhận dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn
chóo quón thì nó dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn dẫn
và mọi người tất cả bà con người sọt đây cũng rất là thử hào
chúng ta có một anh không dẫn dẫn dẫn
mọi người đều điện và nhắc nhở con chảo của mình
của các hấp tập ở nó thiếu
Tại như mái người gái người có chảo
Thì chảo
Bây phía mà chảo chả phía chảo bà
còn này tham được chảo sẽ về cùng người bạn
và không thịt có indem nghĩ nửa nó để phù chảo
và chịt không biết ở chả chảo
bởi vì bạn khi tâm lòng của chảo sẽ từ cao cả
Dạ, giữa lúc mà chếm cho thế nhỉ
thậm thái nào bảo lú thịt tại mình
và phù chảo đổi hỏng sẽ sản xam là giúp bởi gián
và không nâng gại là sự hi sinh
để thân mình để vảo vệ ý gì
cho mọi người
thì trong phía đó nó cũng có phần của con tôi
cho đến tượng sẽ tự hảo ở bên dưới đó
Bà rất tự hảo về người
bây chảo tự tương của bạn
mình sẽ chảo lợi bây tự hảo cho mọi người
cho lợi bây tự hảo của bạn
bây tự hảo của bạn
thì có thể hình xin như nè
trong lòng của mọi người vẫn mại mại có con
Chịt chơi chào, chào tất cả
Hớt dạ, không có lòng